[Música]
en primera plana
carlos
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana analizamos la
figura de isabel segunda la reina eterna
convertida en icono pop nos acompañan en
este estudio luisa corradini
corresponsal de la nación en europa que
conoce muy bien el reino unido luisa
bienvenida comenta es casi del hierro
unatec y periodista independiente
bienvenida a d'elia
a distancia en dúplex nos acompaña a
arnaldo mera historiador especialista en
casas reales europeas arnaldo buenos
días muchas gracias por la invitación y
espero que absolver las dudas que tengan
y espero que esto sea algo agradable
para todos pucha claro que si arnaldo y
también nos acompaña el corresponsal de
recién londres juan carlos bejarano juan
carlos buenos días
carlos y un saludo especial a todos los
compañeros invitados entidades
isabel segunda la reina eterna
convertida en icono pop hoy en primera
plana
[Música]
sus últimas desapariciones habían hecho
especular sobre su estado de salud
isabel segunda tiene 95 años he estado
ausente durante uno de los periodos más
largos de su reinado saltándose los
viajes a irlanda del norte y a la
conferencia de las naciones unidas sobre
el clima en glasgow el pasado abril y
sale segunda perdió a su marido el
príncipe felipe terminando así un
matrimonio de 73 años y una historia de
amor que marcó una larga parte de la
juventud de la reina isabel segundas
están resultando un filón inagotable
para la ficción series películas y
novelas explotan la fascinación por una
figura convertida en icono global y
engrandece en su leyenda con un
personaje que ya es parte de nuestra
cultura popular hoy en primera plana
trazamos el perfil de un personaje
histórico con un recorrido como pocos
han existido antes repasemos algunas
portadas de capítulos que han marcado a
la reina en estos últimos tiempos por
ejemplo está el fallecimiento de su
marido el pasado mes de abril aquí lo
retrata el diario the gardian la peor
crisis institucional con la entrevista
bomba del príncipe harry y merck and mar
coll a ópera en eeuu como recoge esta
otra portada del tabloide el mirror y la
preocupación lo más reciente por sus
problemas de salud como recoge esta otra
portada de metro pero sin duda nos
quedamos para terminar con esta portada
de time que llamaba la reina la reina de
diamante a isabel segunda y se
preguntaba si la monarquía sobrevivirá
cuando ella ya no esté bueno un
personaje de tanto calado histórico lo
podemos abordar sin duda de múltiples
perspectivas luisa desde la
institucional hasta la icónica pop
estamos ante el personaje aún con vida
más relevante históricamente y con más
trayectoria que existe en la actualidad
podemos decir eso
como símbolo de unidad nacional no hay
ninguna duda yo no sé si es el personaje
más relevante de la historia pero es
cierto que es
un símbolo de la historia del mundo de
la segunda mitad del siglo 20 y este
principio de siglo es una mujer que
tiene que ha sido actor de todo lo que
sucedió en este mundo desde la segunda
guerra mundial es una cosa absolutamente
fascinante cuando uno recorre el número
de presidentes que conoció el número de
monarcas que conoció el número de
primeros ministros que conoció es
asombroso y yo quisiera hacer mosca para
poder ver sus cuadernos privados que se
escribe todos los días de su vida para
saber qué es lo que anota yo no sé si
eso lo podremos ver probablemente
nosotros no cuáles creen que han sido
las claves de esta longevidad del ya
bueno ella siempre ha sido muy muy
inteligente en todas las decisiones que
ha tomado cuando tomó el rol de reina
era muy joven ya tenía 25 años comenzó
mostrando un glamour que daba idea a los
cuentos de hadas pero al mismo tiempo
una cercanía mayor cercanía después el
tiempo fue madurando fue aprendiendo
muchas cosas pero siempre se ha
mantenido muy fiel a su carácter estable
y sabiendo sortear las diferentes crisis
que ha pasado tanto inglaterra la
familia real y en general el mundo
enseguida les voy a preguntar por esas
crisis pero antes vamos en este punto
esta reino unido- con nuestro
corresponsal juan carlos bejarano porque
las últimas ausencias en actos visar el
segundo han hecho aumentar las
especulaciones sobre su estado de salud
juan carlos que sabemos al respecto
y realmente estuvo hospitalizada un solo
día tenemos pistas de lo que le puede
estar sucediendo yo creo que los 95 años
cualquier persona incluida la reina pues
va a tener problemas de tipo óseo el
tipo en muscular
por ejemplo el mes pasado la vamos
utilizar por primera vez bastón y
sabemos que ella tuvo una operación en
la en la rodilla derecha hace unos años
y quizás pues nuevamente necesita
utilizar bastón para recuperarse la
hemos visto repito por la edad más
encorvada y el domingo pasado cuando
tenía que aparecer en el homenaje a los
caídos en las guerras pues se dio a
conocer que no podía asistir a esta
importante a este importante evento por
un problema muscular en la espalda esto
no viste nada de gravedad ha cancelado
varios eventos sin embargo ya esta
semana hemos tenido hemos tenido la
posible posibilidad de verla con el jefe
del estado mayor de defensa del reino
unido estaba de pie tiene buen aspecto
así que nada indica que tuviese algo
grave simplemente que los 95 años es
complicado participar en estos eventos
que duran muchas horas en las que ella
normalmente está de pie por cierto que
la reina isabel segunda rechazo educado
y firmemente la distinción como anciana
del año all the year a sus 95 años
porque no se siente tan vieja una solo
responderá reina una solo es tan vieja
como se sienta maravillosa respuesta
y ese es probablemente el secreto del
amor infinito que le tienen que tienen
por ella a sus súbditos
yo te relataba una corta experiencia de
la semana pasada antes de entrar al
estudio hablábamos con un colega nuestro
que trabaja en el 'daily mail' que es un
diario tabloide que sigue de cerca y no
tiene frío en los ojos para contar todas
las problemas que tiene la familia real
y sobre todo los errores que cometen
pues bien este periodista sigue a la
reina desde hace muchísimos años y le
preguntamos pero tú sabes lo que tiene
la reina y él contestó lo siguiente no
lo sé pero si lo supiera no lo diría
ustedes se imaginan lo que significa
para un periodista británico decir tengo
una información que es un boom y yo no
lo diría eso es la reina para los
británicos que viven de ellos viven de
por antonomasia de ello del día que le
parece la respuesta de la reina me
parece magnífica tina dios tiene razón
tiene razón de no haber aceptado
ese premio y creo que es lo que también
ha construido esa
en particularidad que ella tiene que ya
tiene y mantiene a pesar de los 95 años
es su forma de ser directa pero ecuánime
le vamos a preguntar por esta
resistencia
de la monarca al historiador a arnaldo
mera experto en monarquías europeas a
pesar de los años y del cambio en las
las monarquías europeas parece que la
británica resiste mejor arnaldo se debe
únicamente a la figura de saber segunda
debemos entender que la dinastía inglesa
es la más longeva
desde el punto de vista histórico y ella
fue preparada para ser soberana la reina
y no solamente una estructura era toda
una parafernalia sino hablamos en
español de esa palabra esto es ideal en
cuanto a la pompa y circunstancia que
rodea al aparato en sí monárquico yo he
asistido a más de 3 touring de color que
es la ceremonia del aniversario el
cumpleaños real y estará rodeado de
turistas o sea el pueblo británico poco
le importa pero el deslinde turismo les
rinde divisas como diríamos en el país
es una entrada económica muy fuerte
y esa residencia le permite le facilita
ser una reina con un reinado no longevo
porque soy ordenado que es la vida que
le tocó vivir sino un reinado sin
problemas donde ella inclusive ha
ayudado a sus ministros tal vez a ver a
dirigirse a ella por la experiencia que
ella tiene el mejor ejemplo es cuando le
dijo a tony blair es que usted es el
primer ministro que que ha nacido bajo
mi reinado la reina bueno no heredó la
crisis de su tío con óptico pero ha
vivido un reinado tranquilo respecto de
otros reinados chiste las crisis
personales que tenían su reinado y las
había sabido sortear la salida min
hablemos de eso de crisis de momentos
duros porque ha habido múltiples la
pérdida de su marido pero también la de
su hermana margarita en 2002 el trágico
final de lady di y todo lo que se derivó
de aquel capítulo la crisis abierta por
las acusaciones de abuso sexual a su
hijo andrés que su favorito la crisis
reciente de harry mega el mar coll el
llamado mes y cuáles han sido las crisis
que más han marcado a la reina y cómo
conseguir ir venciendo estos episodios
güiza yo creo que lo más duro para ella
la crisis más dura para la reina isabel
segunda fue la crisis de su hijo andrew
que como bien decís era su favorito eso
ha sido una mancha espantosa en en su en
su vida personal en su fuero íntimo pero
la reina tenemos que recordar que la
reina
cuando era una adolescente en su primer
discurso ya dijo yo voy a vivir para mi
pueblo yo voy a vivir para ustedes
defendiendo en lo primero para mí va a
ser siempre gran bretaña una comentó a
su madre hasta este madre arrogante que
madre y de qué esposa y que todo lo
demás ella es reina en consecuencia eso
es como una obsesión para ella y lo
vemos en todos los actos de su vida los
problemas familiares ella es capaz de
incluso hasta ignorarlos públicamente se
ignora yo creo que la única vez que hizo
referencia
aquel año terrible cuando dijo que había
sido un año horrible
un año horribilis había sido si no me
equivoco la separación de su hijo carlos
con diana
en consecuencia pero ese yo creo que fue
la única referencia que hizo a un
problema familiar
lo demás es ella es la reina y no hay
otra cosa y creo que eso es lo que
provoca esa fascinación por parte de sus
súbditos y del mundo entero una
condición de reina por encima de todo no
del ya totalmente carlos y es muy
difícil tener una vida familiar estable
si uno siempre pone en prioridad su rol
en este caso el rol de ella en tanto que
reina no nunca lo ha dividido siempre ha
pasado su rol y eso le ha dejado muy
poco margen de maniobra para ser madre
abuela y esposa porque primero ese rol
tan grande que tiene como reina ha
ocupado el 80 85 por ciento de su vida
por ello capaces las crisis personales
son las que posiblemente la han afectado
más en su imagen y quizás también en su
salud y es una rima que ha sabido yo
pulsando bien la opinión pública
británica para ir modificando ciertas
cosas en el reinado ha tenido ese
termómetro a cerca bueno recordemos que
a nivel bueno fue un invento de ellos en
realidad un invento del príncipe felipe
cuando se habla de la casa real
británica se habla de la firma
no es isabel segunda la que decide toda
esa estrategia tiene un equipo de
comunicadores o de comunicantes que es
absolutamente fascinante hay una
estrategia específica y generalmente ese
equipo le somete a la reina las ideas y
ella después decide pero es cierto que
ella manda mensajes e acordémonos por
ejemplo que en la cop con su ropa con
las joyas que elige en la cop se vistió
de verde todo el tiempo ese tipo de
cosas
excelente van a permitir que hagan una
pequeña pausa en este punto y enseguida
volvemos en primera plana esta hora
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras emisiones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días
intuitivo rápido y en cuatro lenguas
france24 puntocom liberté égalité
actualice
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana analizando la figura de isabel
segunda con las periodistas luisa
corradini delia ron athey y también nos
acompaña el historiador arnaldo mera
experto en casas reales europeas y
nuestro corresponsal en londres juan
carlos bejarano antes de irnos a la
pausa de le hablábamos con luisa de como
la reina sobre todo ese gran equipo de
asesores que por supuesto tiene la casa
real británica han sabido tomar la
temperatura para ir a veces modificando
ciertos aspectos yo recuerdo por ejemplo
tras la fallecimiento de lady di no se
comentó mucho de ese cambio de la
reinado de de volverse más humana sí
totalmente hubo muchas críticas que
siempre han dicho que la reina no es una
persona muy expresiva que no demuestra
mucho sus emociones pero yo creo que
ella el cambio que ha tenido que operar
más notorio es tener en cuenta la
sobreexposición de los medios de
comunicación es decir que su vida y la
vida de todos los miembros de la familia
real se ha escrutado continuamente tanto
en la ficción como en la vida real y ha
tenido que aprender a lidiar con ello yo
creo que ahí se ha visto mayor el cambio
eso es debido directamente a las nuevas
tecnologías es decir ahora hay muy pocas
cosas que quedan en secreto o tras
bambalinas
como siempre ha habido un halo que cubre
un poco la vida de la realeza sobre todo
en inglaterra ella ha tenido que
adaptarse para dejar entrar un poco a
los medios pero siempre guardando
las vamos a hablar de un tema complicado
y espinoso cómo se articula esa relación
entre política y realeza le voy a
preguntar al historiador arnaldo mira
oficialmente la reina no interfiere en
los asuntos de estado pero ha permitido
conservar cierta estabilidad por
supuesto cómo se articula la monarquía
con las instituciones
igual sus relaciones con los ministros
no han cambiado ella no puede ingerir en
política nunca hemos sería un sueño
saber qué opinaba sobre el break si es
verdad es que yo hubiera sido que se
filtrase esa noticia ella ha tenido que
quedarse callada ante el intento de
independencia de escocia que
yo
es la soberana y bueno es otro ejemplo
que tenemos de como ella mantiene
instituciones tuvo que darle la mano y
permitir que se siente en la sala de
banquetes en windsor al
que aquel al que al líder el irá del
movimiento del ejército irlandés que fue
el que ordenó la muerte del tío del tío
de felipe de los combates en febrero se
cumplen 70 años de reinado y ha ido
aprendiendo su cargo todo ella confiado
en sus ministros en que han hecho un
buen gobierno y no estamos exagerando de
que tuvo una relación terrible con
margaret thatcher inclusive margaret
thatcher presidió el desfile de la
victoria de las mañanas las malvinas
cuando yo le tocaba la reina ni siquiera
la invitó a la reina
pero bueno existió su funeral
ahora va a arnaldo de esa relación con
margaret thatcher mucho se ha especulado
luisa de esas relaciones entre isabel 2a
y los sucesivos premiere que han ocupado
el 10 de downing street cómo ha sido esa
relación histórica entre soberana y
premier británico según una juicio de
los biógrafos y de los historiadores la
reina tuvo una relación privilegiada
sobre todo con winston churchill que fue
el primer ministro que le enseñó el
trabajo de reina porque ella accedió al
trono durante el gobierno de winston
churchill después habría tenido una
relación absolutamente
privilegiada con harold wilson que era
un primer ministro laborista
curiosamente por
no absolutamente no ha explicado si una
relación complicada y también ha tenido
relaciones complicadas con otros
primeros ministros por ejemplo
probablemente tenga una relación no
demasiado apacible con el actual
la reina con esa forma de ser que tiene
absolutamente conservadora y rigurosa y
respetuosa de las reglas verían en boris
johnson un personaje demasiado demasiado
extravagante y probablemente
debido a su extracción social porque
boris johnson hace todo lo posible por
mostrarse como perteneciendo a la
nobleza oa la aristocracia cuando no es
así él pertenece a la burguesía no
pertenece a la upper class
aparentemente esa relación sería todavía
peor con el príncipe carlos heredero al
trono nunca sabremos lo que piensa
isabel segunda del éxito aunque como
decía arnaldo nos morimos por conocerlo
y lo que no cabe duda es que tendrá una
posición bien argumentada bien
justificada y con mucho conocimiento
verdad el ya que nunca conoceremos y que
se llevará a la tumba qué pena
no los y de justo estaba escuchando liza
y lo que me parece también interesante
de decir
los primeros son 14 primeros ministros
que ha conocido
si eso es un número pero yo creo que la
relación que siempre ha habido entre los
políticos y la reina es una relación
aparte es decir ella jamás se pone al
mismo nivel de los políticos sobre todo
porque sabe que son efímeros es decir va
a haber uno después del otro
literalmente entonces ya hablamos de una
relación con una jerarquía diferente no
solamente porque ella es representada es
una reina sino porque también ellos van
a pasar ella va a quedar y sobre el
break si yo creo si seguimos más o menos
el perfil que se le ha otorgado a la
reina que es más de derecha por una
derecha moderada yo creo que no no
estaba muy de acuerdo con el break si
hablara hablemos del escenario post
isabel segunda porque claro la sombra
que deja un personaje de este calado
tras de sí es larga y difícil a
reemplazar cuanto menos volvemos a
londres juan carlos como prepara el
reino unido- el escenario post y saber
segunda qué cosas sabemos de lo que
pasará cuando la reina fallezca
pero carlos tenemos entendido que el
funeral de la red inicial segundo está
planificado hace varios años se conocen
algunos detalles por ejemplo que se dará
la señal london bridge ha caído y ahí se
activará este plan que incluye
inicialmente pues trasladar el féretro
de la reina hacia el palacio de
buckingham en el día 2 y esto para
mantener la continuidad de la monarquía
que es supremamente importante el
príncipe carlos será proclamado nuevo
rey es decir y por eso existe el famoso
dicho a muerte el rey que viva el rey la
continuidad es importante es tan
importante que incluso antes de que se
realice el funeral de isabel segunda el
príncipe carlos a partir del cuarto o
quinto día del fallecimiento de su madre
va a realizar una visita a varias
ciudades importantes de reino unido en
opinión por lo que hemos visto las
imágenes de la reina no es que vaya a
suceder
porque no se nos olvide que el próximo
año ya va a celebrar 70 años como
monarca la monarca más mujer más longeva
del reino unido graciasjuan carlos bueno
teóricamente la línea de sucesión es el
príncipe carlos pero hay quien ha
forjado la reina a su imagen y semejanza
según cuentan esa william no a guillermo
su nieto como pasa siempre mucho más
fácil mantener una relación con los
nietos una buena relación que con los
hijos no es cierto y todo el mundo sabe
que la relación de carlos con sus padres
no fue una relación maravillosa es
cierto que carlos tuvo una infancia muy
feliz si se puede llamar a un heredero
del trono de gran bretaña infeliz pero
es cierto que fue tuvo que soportar la
dureza de su padre probablemente la
indiferencia de su madre y las largas
ausencias fue un chico educado y criado
con
nodrizas en consecuencia la relación
siempre fue muy complicada no es lo
mismo con su nieto william que
aparentemente ha asumido
el primer día cuál iba a ser su rol es
un chico que es sensible pero qué es
muy respetuoso de las tradiciones no
como su hermano harry y en consecuencia
la reina tiene una admiración grandiosa
por su nieto no obstante yo no creo que
en algún momento a alguien y sobre todo
a ella se le haya ocurrido la
posibilidad de saltear la línea
sucesoria esto realmente no lo creo por
por como es el personaje de isabel
segunda vamos avanzar porque quiero
hablar de segunda con otra perspectiva
como personaje icónico de lo cultural y
de lo pop historiador arnaldo me era
experto en monarquías europeas le quiero
preguntar la reina se ha convertido en
un icono la fascinación por los su
figura y por la historia de su familia
se ve en la ficción cómo se explica este
fenómeno
hay un interés de la población no
monárquica me refiero de la población en
general y no tampoco en la población
británica me refiero de la población
mundial de saber de la vida de esta
persona que es un personaje público que
es un personaje histórico ya y que ha
sido la soberana de esta es la soberana
en un estado el acercamiento de la
dinastía a la población toda la princesa
diana es innegable
cuando va a visitar a las personas que
tienen sida se están enfermos con sida
nos toca cuando ve el tema de las minas
entonces la serie de clown donde hay
ficción y hay verdad es eso es
importantísimo la gente la ve y la gente
quiere investigar quieren saber qué pasó
y que ha generado todo un nuevo un nuevo
boom mundial de saber sobre esta familia
sobre este personaje históricos
bueno series películas y novelas
explotan la fascinación por la figura de
isabel segunda que se debe esta
fascinación delia es una curiosidad
natural yo creo de saber que se pasa en
la familia real y en particular en la
familia real de inglaterra de esta
persona que se ha mantenido en el poder
por casi 70 años también hay un poco de
morbo de saber los secretos que esconden
con tanta con tanta celosía yo creo que
es un poco de los dos y sobre todo esta
serie de agrado ese es basado sobre
datos históricos por supuesto no está
cien por ciento es será real porque hay
cosas imposibles de confirmar pero es
interesante porque enseña y muestra no
solamente en inglaterra sino en el resto
del mundo realmente cómo se maneja el
gobierno inglés y las tradiciones creo
que es una buena forma también de
presentarse al mundo no creo que te sea
todo malo claro para que hablemos
también de la esa línea difusa a veces
entre la ficción y la realidad quieren
que una serie como de que aún tiene
efectos en la percepción de la monarquía
o la gente distinguir perfectamente una
y otra no no creo que la gente sepa
distinguir la serie está muy bien hecha
como tú decías con mucha razón está
realmente basada en hechos históricos y
después de un poco novelada pero lo que
es fundamental es que esa serie
consiguió justamente
levantar el velo del secreto recuerden
que el lema de la familia real es negro
explain 9 con plane nunca explicar y
nunca quejarse eso es el misterio y el
silencio absoluto yo creo que en eso
reside la fascinación del mundo por
isabel segunda sobre todo en un mundo
donde no hay secreto que dure y que
perdure el crown la serie sirvió para
eso y crown es verdad que expone el
secreto pero una producción de este tipo
creen que más bien beneficio perjudica a
la institución porque también muestra a
la gente las vulnerabilidades de
personajes que pertenecen a la familia
real británica y pueden permitir un
acercamiento yo tengo la teoría que
beneficia el beneficio es cierto que
sabemos que el príncipe carlos está
furioso con el tratamiento que se hizo
de su personaje
hizo una queja formal a los productores
de la serie pero es cierto que
beneficia en el sentido de poder
comprender muchas cosas por ejemplo a
pesar de que carlos no no esté contento
con lo que se dice se sabe por qué
ha tenido una infancia tan difícil
explica y se explica también porque su
padre fue tan duro con con él porque se
cuenta la infancia desgraciada que tuvo
el padre también en el príncipe felipe
en consecuencia naturalmente que eso así
que la gente entienda un poco más todos
esos misterios que rodean a la familia
real pues me quedo sin tiempo para más
muchísimas gracias por haberme
acompañado de elia luis arnal don juan
carlos desde londres ha sido un placer
este programa para analizar todas las
perspectivas de la reina isabel segunda
ya todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
quien en primera plana gracias
[Música]